. This next story is a political story, but
it's also sort of a math story.
You know, I love a good math story.
And this math story has to do with the fact
that a lot of people don't understand percentage
versus percentage points.
Now, to people who do understand the difference.
Please accept my sincere apology that I have
to do this right now.
But the amount of confusion over this over
the last 24 hours has forced my hand and I
have to do this.
So here's the headline.
Donald Trump's approval rating is down 10
points.
Or you could also say 10 percentage points
in the last month.
So early in the Corona virus pandemic, Donald
Trump's approval actually went up all the
way up to 49 percent in the Gallup tracking
poll.
It is now down to 39 percent.
So Trump's approval went from 49 percent to
39 percent.
That's a decline of 10 points.
The problem here is that some people don't
understand the difference between percent
and percentage points.
Others understand the concept, but are using
the wrong term and just confusing other people.
So let's just work through a very quick example.
If someone has 50 percent approval and their
approval goes down by 10 percent.
Strictly speaking, that would mean 50 percent,
10 percent of fifty is five.
That means if you have 50 percent approval
and approval goes down 10 percent, you go
from 50 to 45.
OK, 10 percent.
A 50 is five.
So far, I think, reclear, if you have an approval
of 50 percent and it drops 10 points.
Also said 10 percentage points.
That's a decline of 10 actual points.
Meaning you went from 50 to 40.
You lost 10 points.
Fifty minus 10 is 40.
The confusion comes when we're talking about
percent changes to things already measured
in percent.
OK.
So in this case, are real world numbers are
Trump's approval spiked to forty nine and
then dropped to thirty nine in a one month
period.
That's a ten point decline.
But it is about a 20 percent decline to his
approval.
Right.
If you lose ten out of forty nine, that's
about 20 percent.
And if you're now thoroughly confused, forget
everything I've said.
The news part of this story is that Trump's
approval went from forty nine to thirty nine.
That's a very rapid decline.
In fact, I think it's the largest one month
decline that Trump has seen at anytime during
his presidency.
Now there's good news and there's bad news.
The good news is that.
Clearly, Donald Trump's approval is not immune
from his actions.
In other words, the failed coronavirus response.
The totalitarian instincts that came to light
after the George Floyd killing and the protests
that started this has hurt Donald Trump.
That's good.
He's not immune.
The bad news is that somehow four out of 10
Americans still think he's doing a good job.
So this may be a good time to remind you that
when it comes to presidential approval, when
you think about how divided the country is.
Presidential approval adds up to a hundred,
but there's not really a hundred points of
approval in play.
There's some portion of people who, for ideological
reasons, will never approve of the job that
the president does.
I don't know if that's like, you know, 10
percent, 15 percent, 20.
I'm not really sure.
On the other side, you've got people who will
never abandon Trump no matter what he does.
That could be 15, 20, 25 percent.
I don't know exactly what it is right now,
but the point is, Trump's bottom for approval
is not zero.
And his top four approval is not 100.
Even with George W. Bush, when things were
less partizan after 9/11, Bush saw a massive
spike in approval to 90 or 88 percent, something
like that.
That was probably his ceiling and those were
the absolutely most extenuating circumstances.
So the point is, when Trump's approval moves
from forty nine to thirty nine, forty nine,
thirty nine, it's in that range.
It's really a lot more than that because they're
the bottom is not zero and the top is not
100.
Pick what numbers you think it is with Trump.
It's probably something like I don't think
he is approval, no matter what he does, would
go below 25 or maybe even 28, something like
that.
And I don't think it would go higher than
probably 80 no matter what he does.
So in the context of a range that is more
like 28 to 80, a ten point swing is pretty
significant.
But there's a lot of people in this country
who will never abandon him.
It might be for their own self esteem.
They don't want to admit to themselves that
they made a mistake when they voted Trump
in 2016.
And the way to at least trick your brain into
thinking you didn't make a mistake is to vote
for him again in 2020.
There's this quote incorrectly attributed
to Mark Twain.
It's still a good quote, just not Mark Twain.
The quote is it's easier to fool people than
to convince them that they've been fooled.
And along those lines, we have to understand
why a lot of 2016 Trump voters are going to
vote for him again.
Some may abandon him.
And there's a very small margin there that
Trump can afford to lose before it becomes
almost impossible to win reelection.
But understand, it's easier to fool people
than then to convince them they've been fooled.
And it is very relevant in the Times with
Trump.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more right after this.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram.
For the latest urban garden and poppy updates
at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.